did you see
[Applause]
trump basically declared he's running
again he was talking about drag queen
story hour he's got he's
he's got a whole new act he was in
washington d.c
like a couple of days ago for the first
time since he left office and doing some
of his greatest hits
working in some new [ __ ] he's
he's got a new hunk about he wants to
execute drug dealers
why i just i don't think drug dealers
should be killed unless they're very
very late
and
you know what it was interesting when
trump was in dc a couple days ago you
know who else was there on the same day
making a speech mike pence
awkward
yeah
for old time say trump invited him to
hang
also trump had a golf tournament a
couple of days ago at his new jersey
golf did you see this with the you know
the saudi arabians have a new golf
league everyone has shunned them trump
of course invites them in
uh
i played in a saudi golf tournament once
my handicap was they beheaded my caddy
but
yeah
so he has this golf tournament with the
saudis and 9 11 families thought it was
a little tacky they were very pissed off
about that and here's trump's quote he
said nobody's gotten to the bottom of 9
11.
yes it was probably antifa i imagined
then he said
okay so the saudis did finance
terrorists who crashed planes into the
pentagon but who hasn't sent in a mob to
attack the [ __ ]
a building in washington is where i was
going with him
but
uh
and listen to this the doj the
department of justice says
oh we're getting closer
i think we're going to maybe see a grand
jury they may put trump how about this
for an idea we put trump in jail
and then trade him to russia for
brittany griner
you